mit der impfung ist corona erstmal
vorbei ja so hat sich das irgendwie
zunächst mal angefühlt für einige monate
aber eben leider nur für einige monate
denn nach und nach nimmt die zahl der
antikörper wieder ab der impfschutz also
geht wieder verloren aber wann wann
läuft meine impfung ab wir testen das
heute live den ganzen tag 50 bild
reporter machen live den antikörper test
ja und hier sehen sie es schon ein blick
in das im moment noch fast leere bild
testzentrum bei uns im haus also hier
machen wir gleich den check im bild-test
zentrum ihr checken wir wie stark ihr
schutz gegen korona noch ist wie stark
der schutz unserer bild reporter noch
ist und sie sind hier den ganzen tag
live dabei alles natürlich unter
medizinischer unter fachaufsicht wie
genau läuft das ab mit diesem großen
antikörpertest heute bei bild das wollen
wir wissen von professor karsten watzl
er leitet den forschungsbereich der
immunologie an der tu darmstadt und ist
uns jetzt zugeschaltet schönen guten tag
herr professor axel schunk und tag aus
dortmund
antikörpertest wie läuft das ab wie kann
ich feststellen wie können wir heute
feststellen wie hoch die zahl der
antikörper noch im körper ist
zum einen muss man sagen dass es schon
studien gibt die einfach zeigen dass die
schutzwirkung der impfung mit der höhe
der antikörper korreliert das heißt je
mehr antikörper ich habe desto besser
bin ich wahrscheinlich auch geschützt
das problem was wir aktuell noch haben
ist dass wir keinen festen grenzwert
kennen das heißt ich kann jetzt nicht
sagen genau ab diesem wert ist man auch
genau so und so gut geschützt aber man
kann sicherlich sagen wenn sehr wenig
antikörper vorliegen dass die
schutzwirkung nicht so gut ist und wenn
sehr viele antikörper vorliegen dass man
auch sehr gut geschützt ist das bedeutet
also man kriegt eine zahl der antikörper
raus bei diesem test und dann ist es
quasi eine medizinische auch
individuelle einschätzung ja das reicht
aus nein das reicht nicht so aus
schneller den booster rein
ja im prinzip schon wobei man wirklich
seriös bei wirklich nur zwei zahlen was
sagen kann wenn er halt wirklich sehr
niedrig ist dieser wert dann scheint
kein sehr guter schutz vorzulegen wenn
er sehr hoch ist es der schutz
wahrscheinlich sehr gut es gibt einen
großen bereich dazwischen wo einfach
noch studien fehlen um wirklich zu sagen
ab genau diesem antikörper wert hat man
noch genau eine so viel prozentige
schutzwirkung da werden wir
wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal noch
hinkommen aber da ist die forschung
aktuell noch nicht ganz so weit und
jetzt nochmal ganz konkret was wird da
heute bei uns im haus gemacht also wie
genau läuft er ab der antikörper test
was kostet das ding und wie wird dadurch
geführt
also im prinzip her ist es wird das die
antikörper werden im blut bestimmt das
kann man bei so einem test einfach aus
einen kleinen tropfen aus dem finger aus
der fingerkuppe machen in dem fall ist
es auch noch ein schnelltest das heißt
er muss das blut nicht ins labor
geschickt werden es gibt dann schon
automaten die das analysieren können und
dann wird geguckt genau nach der anzahl
der antikörper die spezifisch für das
bike protein des corona virus sind also
die antikörper die durch die impfung
oder auch durch eine infektion
hervorgerufen worden sind und die kann
ich dann messen und dann gibt es einen
internationalen wert der wirtin bau pro
milliliter pro milliliter ausgedrückt
binden der antikörper units das heißt
damit sind auch verschiedene tests
vergleichbar und dann kann ich auch den
test nicht weil heute hier mache mit
einem test in ann arbor macht
vergleichen wir sind in der ihre
erwartungen wie sehr unterscheiden sich
die werte von geimpften auf der einen
seite und von genesenen auf der anderen
also bei den geimpften sehen wir zum
einen schon mal einen relativ großen
unterschied je nach welchem impfstoff
man hatte da wissen wir zum beispiel
dass leute die zweimal mit moderner
geimpft worden sind somit die höchsten
antikörper spiegel haben am ganz anderen
ende sind die leute die nur einmal mit
johnson johnson geimpft worden sind die
haben im mittel meistens sehr niedrige
antikörper spiegel bei den genesenen die
die infektion durchgemacht haben sind
die antikörper spiegel noch viel
variabler oder finden wir leute die nach
der infektion gar keine antikörper haben
bis hin zu leuten die nach der infektion
so hoher antikörper spiegel haben die
zweifach geimpft und alles dazwischen
also gerade bei den genesenen ist der
schutz sehr sehr variabel danke herr
professor axel sie bleiben uns heute den
ganzen tag über verbunden um das ganze
aus der ferne zumindest zu
beaufsichtigen beziehungsweise vor allen
dingen zu erklären was dann auch für
testergebnisse nachher vorliegen und ab
jetzt wird getestet bei uns hierbei bild
wir gehen jetzt live rhein in unser bild
testzentrum zu unserem bild reporter
kollegen ibrahim k der dort steht und eu
du kannst uns einmal erklären wie geht
das jetzt los was passiert schon gibt
schon die ersten ergebnisse
ja das ist eine interessante frage und
die gewicht direkt weiter an dem mann
der es wissen muss wenn er ist der
leiter der die romed grube perbandt eine
perbandt vielleicht erzählen sie einmal
mehr weil es mich interessiert und
natürlich auch unsere zuschauer und
interessiert nämlich auch die
funktioniert das ganze wieder auf das
ganze ab wie der test abläuft
der test wird genommen wir schlagen vor
das beste mittel ist es nicht weil die
zweite dritte oder vierte wahl antreten
muss haben und da sollte man antikörper
in dem fall kapital wird es gibt auch
die möglichkeit des serums
haben einen speziellen antikörper hessen
nrw test und der schaut wie hoch ist ihr
antikörper spiel der wird ausgewertet
über einen mini labor das in der
neuesten generation wir sind digital
heute sehr weit das gerät ist seit acht
wochen auf den markt und dann kriegen
wir den genauen spiegel der
antikörper die sie in ihren grund haben
gemessen auf 20 oder 100 m und da sehen
wir dann das gerät druck genau aus dem
busch gehen sie in welchem status
ungefähr wie hoch ist ihr antikörper
spielt und warum ist warum ist diese
info überhaupt so wichtig also warum
muss ich wissen wie hoch meine
antikörper spiele ist wenn er da
streiten sich die gelehrten drüber es
gibt sehr viele impfungen in deutschland
da kriegen sie nicht die nach impfung
bevor sie nicht einen täter wehrte habe
nicht wo man sagt okay ihr spiegelt es
hoch genug ich kann nicht einfach nach
hinten ich pumpe jetzt mal rein in den
körper ist ja nicht so schlimm es ist
ganz wichtig dass wir alle geimpft
werden aber die zweite oder dritte oder
vierte impfung der würde schon mal
schauen ist ein mensch noch geschützt
hat ja ein spiegel von drei oder vier
1000 dann schadet sagen ja die die
impfung nicht aber es ist überflüssig
sagen die meisten mediziner wir selber
kennen ganz ganz viele her zu sagen nein
ich möchte schon wissen hat jemand noch
genug schutz ist es überhaupt nötig da
jetzt noch mal zu spritzen es ist jetzt
hier um gottes willen kein aufruf
zusammen meine herrschaften dadurch mich
irgendwie im gegenteil ist die
wichtigste waffe die wir haben aber
aktionismus dass man jetzt also wird
nicht jedem zwischen 20 und 50 sage ich
immer gesunde menschen ohne
vorerkrankungen die 22 haben bereits da
sollte man doch eventuell schon mal
staunen hat den spiegel von 1000 2000
3000 dass man dann erstmal den link wo
es ganz dringend nun man sagt okay wir
haben ältere leute wir haben früh
erkannte wir haben momentan wieder nicht
so viel sagt ihm habe ich gehört die
teststation sind alle dicht das mandat
vorziehen und sagt was ist jetzt
wirklich dringend und das sollten
einheiten ok jetzt höre ich persönlich
heraus wenn mein wert bei so 2000 3000
4000 liegt dann bin ich quasi ich finde
den begriff nämlich so interessant
gepustet ohne quasi diese booster
impfung bekommen zu haben ist das so das
ist ich habe mit sehr vielen medizinern
zu tun dieses gerät wurde bis jetzt von
über 3.000 medizinern gekauft und die
vertreten auch die meinung gibt dann
natürlich sage noch einmal das wird
heute so gesagt wenn sie noch eine
chance kriegen schadet nicht das wird
wohl auch so sein aber wir haben ganz
viele leute gut die haben jetzt einen
etat von 30 50 oder 100 aber wir haben
auch sehr viele mit 2.000 3.000 nicht
also die jede menge antikörper noch
weniger blut hat polizisten rumfliegen
haben und dann teilweise vor aktionismus
teilweise jetzt bin ich gespannt
deswegen haben wir bei uns bei bild live
heute zu diesem großen bild
antikörpertest aufgerufen und wir haben
einige kollegen die hier sind und ich
sehe gerade schon mein bild kollegen
julius bilden julius du bist heute hier
du lässt sich heute auch testen warum
das nicht essen ja wir über knapp
richtet sich damit viel beschäftigen
weiß ja die menschen die gefährdet sind
vor allem alte ältere menschen menschen
mit vorerkrankungen und bei jungen
menschen sagt man man weiß gar nicht ob
infiziertes man könnte es trotzdem in
sich tragen auch wenn man es gar nicht
mehr keine symptome hat und ich würde
gerne mal wissen
ob ich irgendwann krone hatte ohne es
wirklich zu wissen und vielleicht meine
familie meine mutter in gefahr gebracht
habe ohne es wirklich zu merken und ich
hoffe dass an diesem an den werten die
jetzt gleich ausgelesen werden ablesen
kann bist du bisschen nervös so ein
bisschen angst vor diesem test oder wie
sieht die stimmungslage hier film
gesehen es ist ein bisschen härter als
der kommune fest wird abgenommen vom
finger da will ich bin ich nicht ich bin
doch eigentlich ich hoffe dass ich die
klappe habe ich bin eigentlich hätte
johnson & johnson wurde jetzt vor zwei
tagen sogar noch gebucht hat ich bin mal
gespannt inwiefern sich das dann im
bilde abzeichnet dann würde ich sagen
wollten wir das mal ein hohn sprechen
später noch mal danke dir gehen wir
diese schlange mal weiter und ich habe
nämlich eben schon gesehen hier ist
jemand den sie kennen nämlich unsere
bildschirm chefin tanja meyer hallo
zahlen schuldig zu sehen
tanja warum bist du heute hier erzählen
uns mal warum lässt du dich heute testen
deswegen würde ich das jetzt gerne
wissen ich bin gespannt als wir uns und
den zuschauern doch mal warum es
möchtest du dich pusten lassen weil ich
mich einfach sicherer fühlen also ich
bin ja schon viel unterwegs auch sitzen
flieger ich treffe natürlich auch
menschen das ist klar und ich möchte für
mich einfach sicher sein und deswegen
möchte ich den dritten buchstaben ist
hat julius ja gerade schon angerissen es
wird blut abgenommen bis zu ein bisschen
aufgeregt so nervös ich war in der tat
ein bisschen nervös weil ich gehört habe
es geht einmal ins ohren einmal den
finger und mir wurde dann aber gesagt es
wird gar nicht wer also macht das ohr
jetzt habe ich gehört hier wird im
finger gemacht aber ich habe schon
gespickt also die kollegen haben zwar
das hat nicht wehgetan okay ich bin sehr
gespannt was dabei rauskommt und wir
nehmen uns jetzt irgendeinen kollegen
raus nicht irgendein daniel du bist
nämlich unser verband der quasi mit uns
nach vorne geht aber wir einmal kurz
rüber schränken uns das anschauen da
wird gerade noch bei der kollegin ein
test gemacht und wir warten hier einmal
ganz kurz ab und werden dann rüber gehen
und mit adriano zu color sprechender uns
nämlich erklären wird was genau macht
wie das ganze abläuft wie lange wir
zuwarten haben und so was ganz
interessante ganz spannende fragen
daniel wie sieht eigentlich bei dir aus
gerade bist du jetzt ein bisschen
aufgeregter vor ihr tatsächlich schon
also sowohl das ergebnis als auch ob der
pieks jetzt weh tut oder nicht richtig
gut ich hatte auch augsburg wie tanja
und aber ich glaube auch den finger
werden leben warum hast du dich
entschieden heute hier zu sein und sich
testen zu lassen ehrlich gesagt pure
neugier also ich hab nämlich ein relativ
standardmäßige geschichte ich bin
zweimal geimpft und aber auch keine
große nebenwirkung oder irgendwelche
verdachtsmomente gehabt aber was mich
wahnsinnig dass hat die unsicherheit
dass man eigentlich nichts richtig klare
antwort kriegt wenn ich zumindest für
mich weiß okay antikörper sind da sieht
gut aus ich habe werd ichs oder so
irgendetwas oder alternativ mitspieler
kaum was vorhanden der booster ist
dringend nötig würde es mir zumindest
ein bisschen ruhe geben ich bin sehr
gespannt was bei dir gleich raus kommen
gehen so langsam ein bisschen drüber
so langsam rüber und schauen uns das an
perfekt so und jetzt sind wir auch da
ich gerade schon vorgestellt adriano zu
carl soballa freut mich auch schön dass
die leute hier sind schön dass die zeit
gefunden haben erzählen sie uns doch
einmal anhand von daniel was genau
passiert und schön detailliert damit der
zuschauer damit wir verstehen was er
überhaupt jetzt stattfindende super also
fangen jetzt erst mal so hier haben wir
den neutralisieren antikörpertest wir
machen erstmal will ich dass wir haben
die
fischstäbchen hier ähnlich wie bei den
antiken tests aber aktiv arbeiten wir
mit blut diskutierte ist relativ simpel
erstmal das klassische finger
desinfizieren ich bin für den kleinen
finger bluteten mal so ganz nett naja
also nicht wahr dass ich auch so bis
infizieren kurz einwirken lassen 30
sekunden
jetzt das interessiert mich jetzt warum
jetzt 30 sekunden ein wirklich weil es
in der zeit erstmal alles verdammt und
im endeffekt da die zeit bis 16 uhr
stattfindet für 30 sekunden zu wenig und
so ist es einfach am besten dass es
trocken ist okay und wenn wir jetzt
überlegt schon bei sekunden sein sind
interessiert mich und die zuschauer
natürlich wie lange dauert das überhaupt
jetzt alles wie lange dieser test also
mit haben wir mit der bearbeitung sind
wir sind mit 90 sekunden meistens durch
bisschen geredet haben dann seinen
minuten und dann wenn man das dann und
erst rein tut weil fertig 15 15 minuten
und nachher mir das ergebnis der krise
interesse und dann warten wir jetzt
gleich mal darauf dass wir zum gerät
über gehen weil das team schon ganz
spannend ausgeschrieben einmal kurz
links und schauen uns das mal an so das
ist also das gerät ist übrigens das habe
ich vorab schon erfahren zweimal
dieselbe gelegt es gibt einmal dieses
große gerät das so ein bisschen lagarde
maschine handelt von der größe und
einmal dieses portable gerät im
endeffekt beide dieselbe funktion wobei
dieses größere geräte links bis zu acht
tests gleichzeitig machen kann so und
jetzt sind wir schon weiter wir gucken
einfach noch mal rüber da hat schon den
fix bekommen
so dass die zuschauer nicht gehört dass
ich habe sie verstanden und es tat
überhaupt nicht wie sehr schön alles
geworden ist gerade gehört
so und das ist auch nicht weiter blutet
und dann geht es ganz sind wir machen
das wir haben ein neues blut nur der
puffer lösung wir vermengen die das blut
mit der prüfer lösung
und tun das ins stäbchen isst ende
tatsächlich einem anti diente sie und
dann wartet man bis blau anzieht wenn
das der fall ist so wie jetzt heißt es
die biologie arbeite und dann nimmt man
diesen test wir haben die wahlen einen
kleinen gerät eine sekunde bevor wir
hingegeben einmal kurz darüber würde
sagen damit für einmal von hinten sehen
können wie das ganze aussieht das
interessiert mich nämlich jetzt auch so
bezeichnen schauen natürlich niemand ist
so nah dran wie wir so mit dem kleinen
gerät funktioniert ob die art und weise
haben würde den stäbchen jetzt eine
viertelstunde liegen lassen das stäbchen
reintun test drücken nach sieben
sekunden ist das ergebnis da will man
das einmal ein bisschen erst einmal
entspannter machen aber der gegner macht
man das ins große gerät rein das große
gerät
saugt design blühte das schon aus und
hinter zeit nehme ich dann den namen die
daten des patienten auf und nach 15
minuten habe ich dann das ergebnis
direkt ausgedruckt sogar dann würde ich
sagen machen wir das jetzt gleich war
jetzt will sie nicht interessant ich hab
noch eine frage hätte ich daniel was
gerade schon gesagt du bist auf geregnet
was erwartest du für ein ergebnis das
meiste wird rauskommen
ich habe vorher keine wette
abgeschlossen ich dachte vielleicht
gibts bei mir gar nicht ganz so gut aus
weil ich nach den impfungen überhaupt
keine nebenwirkungen oder irgendetwas
hatte und deswegen immer dieses jahr
okay dann hat der körper nicht richtig
gearbeitet vielleicht hat es gar nicht
so viel gebracht also ich fürchte ich
bin nicht ganz ganz vorne mit dabei ok
dann warten wir mal dein ergebnis jetzt
ab aber ihr habt ja schon oben zwei
kollegen die ihre ergebnisse haben
deswegen würde ich sagen er war einmal
rüber ins studio und schauen uns deren
ergebnis sagen wir sprechen mit denen
danke eu tatsächlich ist es so bei uns
schon besucht die ersten unser 50 bild
reporter sind nämlich schon bei uns in
diesem großen antikörper test den wir
heute in unserem test zentrum wir haben
es gerade gesehen bei uns im bild haus
durchführen den ganzen tag über also
einmal vorgestellt hier in der runde und
kollegin bettina kochheim schönen guten
tag und victor wachse unser kollege
bettina du nicht irgendeine kollegin du
auch nicht viktor aber du bist
gleichzeitig unsere medizin experten
hier im haus und war ist heute die erste
die den stich bekommen hat wo genau
wurde gar eingestochen bei ihrer wurde
hier man sieht es noch so ein ganz
kleines bisschen in den kleinen finger
region mit mit nähnadel aber es tut
wirklich überhaupt nicht mein kleiner
pieks für eine große wirkung einmal
bevor wir auf den zettel gucken denn da
steht dein ergebnis drauf bettina deine
geschichte du bist wahrscheinlich als
eine der ersten in deutschland game
stolz medizinexperten oder wann wurde
bei dir ja alles und zweitimpfung
durchgeführt aber ich musste mich da
auch ein bisschen an die prioritäten
halten und ich war dann ende mai habe
ich meine zweite impfung bekommen mit
biontech tatsächlich wurde dass da auch
im abstand von drei wochen gemacht dann
gab es also diskussionen drei wochen
sechs wochen das ist dann zwischendurch
auch mal geändert worden aber ich hatte
meine erste impfung anfang mai und die
zweite dann ende mai ende mai also
rechtzeitig vom sommerurlaub vor den
sommerferien du hast ja auch kinder
jetzt einmal danach gesund geblieben
oder noch mal gepostet oder was ist
danach passiert ja ich hab dann
tatsächlich im spätsommer habe ich dann
trotzdem corona bekommen ist zu
erkranken ich bin erkrankt tatsächlich
auch mit symptomen also bei uns nicht so
dass ich nicht gemerkt hätte lieber
gehören fieber hat sich tatsächlich
nicht aber ich hatte diesen klassiker
dass ich glaube zehn tage komplett kein
geruch und geschmack mehr hatte und ich
fühlte mich hat sehr erkältet
und das auch wirklich lange die symptome
haben gehalten aber es war jetzt kein
schwerer fall das heißt du hast die
volle dröhnung corona bekommen so zu
sagen du bist zweifach geimpft hast dann
selber noch dich infiziert also hat es
tatsächlich eine corona erkrankung die
noch nicht so lange her ist jetzt müsste
eigentlich zu erwarten sein du hast
relativ gute antikörper werte aktuell
höchsten raten das einmal auf vielleicht
die kamera hast dich dran der wichtigste
zettel heute der große bild
antikörpertest was ist rausgekommen bei
dir bediener zeigt man einmal den zettel
kleben die kamera ganz groß kommt man
nach an hier kommt einmal ran an
bettinas zettel und da zeigen wir einmal
den ganz entscheidenden wert ich komme
aber zu dir über und zeigt mal einmal
hier auf diese zahl halte mal kurz rein
bitte bettina das ist die zahl auf die
es ankommt das ist
2615 wenn ich das richtig erinnern kann
das lassen wir uns einmal einordnen von
ja aus ärztlicher sicht von professor
watzl der uns zugeschaltet ist grüße sie
noch einmal
2615 bei unserer kollegin bettina
kochheim gut oder schlecht sehr gut also
das ist ein wert wir sicherlich mit oben
mit dabei ist da ist von einem sehr
guten schutz auszugehen weil
letztendlich ist das ja jetzt bei ihr so
gewesen dass sie ihren booster schon
bekommen hat in dem fall nicht durch die
dritte impfung sondern durch die
infektion und wir wissen mittlerweile
dass die kombination aus infektionen
impfung mit den besten schutz gibt
leider haben die meisten leute das
falsche gemacht die haben sich erst
infiziert und lassen sich dann in dem
fall ist es richtig rumgelaufen erst in
erst geimpft und dann war auch die
infektionen man hat es gemerkt aber wie
gesagt kein schwerer verlaufen da hat
die impfung im prinzip genau das getan
was sie tun sollte und was sie jetzt
sicherlich hat ist ein guter schutz
damit kommt sie auch durch den winter
sie braucht sich jetzt sicherlich nicht
ein drittes mal impfen lassen also alles
super gelaufen heute für bettina
kochheim alles richtig gemacht hat
professor wir schauen uns nochmal die
skala an auf die es ankommt also dein
wert
2615 kann einmal ganz kurz die
antikörper skala sozusagen zeigen die
wir hier drüben auf dem bildschirm haben
also wo fängt der rote bereich an wo der
grüne bereich ab 3.000 etwa vielleicht
können wir einmal rüber schenken an
unsere große tafeln an bei 3000 das ist
der messwert wo der grüne bereich
beginnt also wenn sie da liegen dann
sind sie wirklich top top job geschützt
alles über 1000 ist aber auch richtig
gut so wie eben unsere kollegin bettina
kochheim und bei den kleineren
zweistelligen zahlen da wird es dann eng
da geht es in den roten bereich so um
die 20 da muss man sich wieder sorgen
machen das doch die nächste impfung
fällig ist victor wachs auch unser bild
reporter kollege bei uns im studio soll
man natürlich von dir auch wissen erst
mal ganz kurz erzählt du bist auch
geimpft ich bin auch geimpft zweimal
astrazeneca die zweite impfung war am 11
juni diesen jahres und dann im juli
hatte ich direkt corona
fünf wochen danach und ich habe es
gemerkt weil ich meinen geruch und
meinen geschmack sind verloren habt aber
ansonsten hatte ich keine symptome also
auch zweifach geimpft auch erkrankt er
eigentlich ganz ähnliche geschichte auch
wenn die zeiträume ein bisschen anders
waren wie bei bettina auch bei dir
müsste der wert jetzt richtig gut sein
dass es drauf gucken oder ein ergebnis
zettel viktor
darauf mit der kamera was ist die
entscheidende zahl bei viktor was ist
dein wert sagt einmal der ist 1695 und
ich bin ein bisschen neidisch auf
bettina nicht weniger als zu aber
immerhin bin ich auch im grünen bereich
sozusagen und gleich noch mal rüber zu
unserem professor heute früh auch dass
ein top-wert ich glaube viktor muss ich
auch damit überhaupt keine sorgen machen
richtig herr professor axel richtig auch
er ist ja im prinzip drei mal geimpft
also zwei mal wirklich mit der spritze
und einmal durch das virus wir wissen
natürlich dass wenn man zweimal mit
astrazeneca geimpftes die antikörper
spiegel nicht ganz so hoch sind das
könnte auch hier die erklärung sein
warum er dann trotz der infektion nicht
ganz so hohe antiker bei spiegel hat wie
die kollegin können aber letztendlich
ist es auch eine gewisse variabilität
aber auch hier ist von einem guten
schutz auszugehen danke für die schnelle
einordnung wir werden das den ganzen tag
genau so machen denn wir wollen von
allen unseren reportern wissen wie hoch
ist aktuell der antikörper spiegel der
große bild antikörpertest heute bei uns
im haus den ganzen tag über sie sind
live dabei und der test ist richtig gut
gestartet werden ganz schnell innerhalb
weniger sekunden
dessen ergebnisse bekommen von bettina
kochheim von victor wachs beide
ergebnisse richtig gut nicht so ganz
verwunderlich beide zweifach geimpft
beide tatsächlich danach einen
durchbruch gehabt beide tatsächlich
erkrankt und bei jetzt aber mit
absoluten top werten wir sind gespannt
auf kollegen die keine erkrankung hatten
die möglicherweise auch die impfung
schon vor langer zeit vorgenommen haben
so wie eben von unserem kollegen daniel
böcking gehört ist er möglicherweise die
zahl der antikörper deutlich gesunken
also das werden wir ihnen den ganzen tag
hier live bei bild präsentieren der
große bild antikörpertest heute und
damit zurück zu dir patricia